um you know I always forget I'm going to
kiss your ass a little bit here because
known you a long time we've been doing
stand-up a long time and I always
mentioned various female comics that I
liked like Eliza or different people I
always forget to include you just how
you're making me feel you know it is
because I remember I remember night your
dream that's on forgive me because
you're I watched you do a set at the
Westside comedy theater and you and I
came out to afterwards I think I was
like it was so fun is so unique maybe a
year ago no way it was yes yes way
got up in her I remember your joke was
last time you lied about a year ago I
only come to the west side one position
oldest fan it was so funny and I went
well there's an example of a a woman who
is as funny as any man working right now
but you earn that but Brian don't you
think we're just out of place now where
people are comics and they're funny know
what I mean by that is that that takes a
lot of work and it takes a lot of kind
of trial and error and you've been doing
it for a long time and no I don't I
don't think you'd be as funny as what I
saw you do or you know people aren't
funny
most men are funny correct most you know
I'd say like 5% of any anyone is going
to be funny John Thomas in general oh
yeah I mean the the baseline isn't like
everyone's hilarious it's like you know
so all the women who are doing is
they're obviously not all going to be
funny just like all the men aren't funny
and there's more men so there's a lot
more so there's going to be more funny
men because there's just more men doing
it is very true but you're very good
thank you I feel very odd Kampai knows
whether you are really a lot of ways I
for always forget what a great comics
what do you say you say Eliza and then
who else use Maria Bamberger Eliza every
advantage
Sanford I mean I've got my I've got my
list of female comics that I think they
cracked me up that make me laugh and are
they damn effort from the male comics
you don't just have comic people one
because we always inevitably talk about
like well how many are women funny how
many women are funny and you hear this a
lot from guys oh you know I don't know
how many you know and then there's all
this weird competition with women that I
see and people saying stuff and I'm
always like what's the weird
yeah what world that CB I think you
going down to a super weird road no no I
think I think a lot of it the
competition comes from because Amy
Schumer burst on the scene she's all
over I think she gets a lot of criticism
so that's when it became for a lot of
comics I think or even could critic or
audience men versus women right because
she was like the biggest thing I know
you think men got jealous
yeah oh why don't we got males I'm
talking about louis c.k five years ago
now erwin sorry my Amy Schumer it's like
I don't know it's a lot I think that's
where it comes from I really does
actually come from well III don't know
that it's jealousy or maybe it's like
there are the women out there that have
the same chops and you know maybe they
don't get the same cool because amy was
the thing what brings it up is because
Amy at that time and like trainwreck and
everything should buy the biggest comic
in the world at the time she's female I
mean so much has to happen for something
like that to happen to you I mean it has
to be like you know a little petri dish
of like every single element like it
doesn't I mean of course Amy's very
talented but you know there's there's so
many you know like she's resonating with
people for whatever reason and
something's happening in the world
that's making everyone resonate to her
yeah and then she also has a movie
coming out and she also you know they
don't Russell and it's like so much has
to kind of culminate right so obviously
there's going to be people who are
talented who aren't getting what they're
trying to say she's getting but to go
back to there is a division right there
the people do talk about female and male
comics of course she does but people
talk about male comics and female comics
they just do that's that's the
conversation right I mean I'm sorry but
my friends don't yeah but your friends
are are colonics will be cool whatever
but but their thing Amazon about it you
know I'm an ex-jock I don't have that
conversation either we hadn't skunk
around white homes were you talking
about with Pete Holmes but it's not like
a daily comic like I never look at a
comic so it's men versus women are a
comic like god I want to fall female
comic er no I mean that's the case at
all but I don't think it's a popular
subject around the world the point I'm
making is to go back to it as if they're
funny comic and I always forget to
include you when you're little female
comic now let me ask you this would you
include me if they said who are your
favorite comic yeah I do it all time you
would include me I would
obscenity the way I memory about circle
do you I know the way I include Maria
Bamford or or iliza shlesinger yes 100%
I do I mean I think I do that those
Natasha because it is still a pretty
male world and it's pretty like you know
and women like it's it's still fairly
male-dominated so you know that's that's
probably why I include that right do you
think so or now um I mean it's hard
because like every female comic I know
has their own show
so but I don't you but I didn't but I
might be seeing it from you know a dip
like a you know a special remind it well
I'm just saying I I know so many
successful female comedians that's all
yeah but I'm sure there's plenty who
aren't successful yet yeah I just yeah
that's a good point I feel like there's
a ton of successful I mean I think this
is a really cool time to be a woman and
if I were an audience member I would
rather I mean women are just they have a
more unique perspective I think than
just like an average white male and I'm
actually I kind of feel like a lot of
white men are having a hard time right
now because they're not exotic enough or
I don't know but maybe I've heard that
complaint from me too I mean I've heard
more of that than I have you know it's
harder to get a writing job sometimes
well that's a lot of pressure everybody
like guys it's a lot of pressure on
networks you know when to have a diverse
writing staff and a diverse cast that's
just a fact of life
now then they're pretty plating him back
KY KY there were two people trying to be
writers on my show and they were like
100% equally funny and one was a woman
and one woman was a man it would
definitely go to the woman Clarkson and
if it was an Asian guy and a white guy I
would definitely watch it ya know Paris
yeah I thought we were reports that is
the true the same degree of funny just
because like there's what we want
diversity it's not even the pressure
it's like you want that in your room
because it just creates more prospective
more perspective more interesting unique
perspectives my thing is you want the
funniest person I agree that's mine I
totally agree that's why I said if all
things were equal yeah but they're gonna
have different perspectives
they're all so young grow up different
Asiad yeah that's for sure
but it is a good time because I'm
something of like in the 70s there was
Gilda Radner there was a couple of
female comics but it was almost all male
right I mean how many there was always
funny like Lily Tomlin and I don't
matter come and sit on really well more
the victors weren't they they weren't
there Madeline Kahn wasn't really a
standard no I'm shopping who the female
comics are because this is kind of a
renaissance for female comics right now
I think it's a Renaissance for comedy
yeah you know like it seems like great
comic rubber well it also seems like we
have so many opportunities I mean
there's so many clubs and so many
specials and right and you've been in TV
shows like when I started I don't know
when did you start started in 2000 1923
I write a dozen I think you I think you
were already established when I started
problem star in 2002 yes not that long
ago
I mean 17 years seems like a long time
ago comedy and verse 16 15 Agana
saloon so all right but let me tell you
this like when I started not one
comedian we knew who was established had
a TV show that's true zero and we used
to talk about like Rhett Butler she was
the one who you know and everyone would
say like it's not those days anymore
comics don't get shows you know that
those days are over
you're saying female no all in 2002 yeah
no one had their own show and now it's
like every single don't really know
nobody's like them some was the only she
was the only one in here in 80s comic
right yeah Ben he made his bones on
Johnny Carson he'd been doing it forever
and then he never went share with
Seinfeld but like other than like
development deals for stand-up it was
basically I remember managers would say
yeah it's just not the 80s anymore every
every eighties comment got us well I got
three I got I think three or four
development deal really yes and so I
what I would do is I'd get to LA you do
a showcase you get a development deal I
would do a you know honey yeah be like
220 grand or something and then I'll be
Territorian Grantham's just like that or
or sure well then you owes me that night
no but what would happen what a terrible
businessman you do a pilot like I did a
pilot called being Dunbar and there was
a I think it was between Fox and one of
the network or the same that were I did
I think was ABC and they kind of decided
they wanted to essentially rent you for
the
season so they want to do a development
deal around you which means that like
ABC couldn't have Brian go anywhere else
Boston so you're you're a young guy
you're 30-something and you know 32 or
in the bay and they're like that guy is
going to be the next star that's what
they say so they go we'll buy you so I
remember I remember I went with Fox I
think because they ended up giving me
something like 220 230 I was a lot of
money turns pretty good right for nut
for doing nothing of course nothing
happened I don't even think I had an
audition nobody of course about he did
random they would just keep doing and in
fact it was even crazier than that
because I had a meeting with Disney I
think and I got in the room and I was
just a meeting and they said we love
what you do we think you're great we
think you're going to be the future who
creepy we want to lock you up and they
gave me a deal they were able to dictate
to the they had a development deal I
guess with the network and they were
able to give me money to keep me there
that's how obvious don't make are let me
start by doing open mics like the
typical I want open night since just
kept doing open mics yeah honey everyone
starts doing that yeah but by the way I
got one of those development deals with
NBC for about the same amount of money
and I just decorated my house and I was
like well how do I do that like and I
remembered oh I just spent all that
money and like made the house look
amazing
yeah it don't still do that right like
no awesome Martin Dahlin well just
throwing money like oh here you go
here's oh I I think what I was I what I
should have started this whole
conversation with I saw you when you
first started you know I'm all gone I've
seen years ago yeah I'm old enough to
have remembered all of this when you
were beginning to do comedy just like
with iliza shlesinger and just would
like a library probably started with on
how to end Whitney way before no we all
start way out for me right so so for me
to see you know people who started when
I was already doing a lot of stand-up to
you know to be that good it's just
really cool to watch it's really cool to
go [ __ ] man
that's what hard working a lot though be
right like you've seen her I've seen
Chris D'Elia
is this okay I need your Chris Chris was
my class I feel like me Eliza Whitney
Chris that was really 2006 um Jen
Kirkman we all kind of started together
a great class
it's a great Morgan Murphy I just
remember those are the people like I had
work
was it open mics with I was with Morgan
I did it I did a thing where I was
headlining a whole a whole tour and
Morgan was one of the beat people that
would open up so yeah I mean well there
were people starting at around the same
time but in Chicago like Pete Holmes and
Kumail they were all like in Chicago I
think doing it but I think they were
around the same I did it I did a
showcase with Chelsea Handler I mean
remember back and Chelsea was like a
little more established sworn us but but
I again I'll reinforce your middle
region man for they were kind of like
mmm Patton LLC wasn't in that group
Chelsea he wasn't no God
she got girls behaving badly but why
well I remember we both did this then we
even drove there together we did this
showcase for Jamie Masada I was it a lot
factory for you and it was like seven
minutes and I got up and did some weird
things she did her thing and I remember
when she got gross behaving badly I was
like good on her you know I feel I feel
like Chelsea's one of those talents she
I feel like she's always working that
she's always finding women we're always
working
well it's correct like as a job finding
work and always having a real yes like I
feel like she's always whether one door
shuts like Jessie lately and she signs
on to do a Netflix yeah this show has
been what what the Chelsea Lately show
was I don't know it's completely
different the scripted reality show cut
you are you are doing what now on Comedy
Central you have your own show right
that you prima show called another
period which takes place in the Gilded
Age in Newport Rhode Island John Kerry
pressure on Comedy Central that's around
1902 to see you I know you guys are into
sports I don't know if you have a good
good time look at you think is in a
sports show I wish I'm gonna [ __ ]
sports you you're in a sports yours
they're all the [ __ ] on the TV and
they love the food he's a good dude okay
but there was and then you do know
anything about sports at all like you
know what a quarterback is that's
football well do you know what he what
he does the quarterback um I don't know
the for the refrigerator Perry a quarter
yeah there we go
I remember the Super Bowl shuffle except
on Oxford oh good god I wish I didn't
wear sports shirt Rockford what Illinois
okay I just liked you to show though I
mean I could maybe play tennis
aesthetically I have like
connection to it I like the outfit I
like the lifestyle I like the idea of
like playing some games and then like
having a drink I tell me you are always
generally exhausted by my male energy
like way to put hey baby
no no I say something inappropriate she
be like is your husband they do the
exact opposite of right no no he's got a
lot of energy but I have to say that I
was thinking on the way here that Brian
must be a really good dad because you
have so much energy I think so
I play with my kids a lot yeah like
you're and you're always in a good mood
like it's just like a that's a great
quality I mean I'm kind of like always
fighting this sort of blase yeah my my
daughter
most people are though Brian has some
sort of weird energy I don't know what
energy to though uh loud I might have
guys against ours we don't really I
don't feel my daughter
I got war my house my mom my wife said
that my daughter came down and I was on
the road the other day and she goes I'm
bored
say what daddy's not here your wife's
not playing like you play no no I play
you will have more energy than them I
just compliment I come downstairs and
I'm like I told Peter Pan I want some
collarbones for breakfast no I like and
the only place you save is that gas but
you're so far away from in doing what is
right screaming and then I let off the
couch and I keep them there until they
go home until they're 16 and your
exhaust I'm gonna kick you up there are
neighbors also there already is also
with what they're already exhausted with
me they roll their eyes at me
I tell people all the time Bieber like
who was outside our friend in Toronto
next to you and Brian hanging out a ton
after the podcast I'm like not really is
exhausting ya know like I mean Brian are
basically marriages our business we
travel together just like you and your
husband have a tour come on me and Brian
tour together basically married do you
guys enjoy this podcast together yeah
that's cool it's pretty exciting then
you go to like theaters and have live
well we're married we're married live
perform but I like spend time with you I
never get tired with you know time you I
feel like maybe you get tired of me I
don't really get tired we just have a
lot of energy I like to hang out
yeah I mean I don't know like you and
daliyah I'm good for an hour if you
deleted me yeah delete your kind of
energy right yeah it's showing keys I
don't have it I don't I'm something
wrong the other day with the Christmas I
our comedy that energy well being silly
silly yes because that's something that
I always like in comedians yeah well
Brian and Chris Murphy comedians there
you go
thank you well you have Natasha's gonna
do 20 minutes for us right now
Brian one of my favorite male comedians
like you know go live and I'll be
hanging out my chick friends yeah good
all the Broads are hanging out we're
like all your favorite male comedians
you know in our life isn't we Homer
don't mention you but seriously your
favorite thing I don't know as you doing
I was like like this it's true no you
aren't seriously one of my favorite male
yeah if she remembers you you are dude I
thought of it the other night when
you're at the [ __ ] college store and
I was like Natasha Natasha nice man you
guys drive my rap was up we were talking
to dice man it was me the whole the dice
man doing this was on the dice they're
referring to just the digest when he was
known as but he does said at the store
right oh yeah he was there and he's
still like I play his wife on the
Showtime show oh that's right didn't
even say min oh you know what I sold two
minute that's too much bullets so many
people have their own show no you can't
watch them all nice you plays a gun show
time
yes all his girlfriend wears the season
to come out of Turner's
finger Louis on the show it's called a
dice dice and he does the Oh like you
still doing all that all done I'm too
young for and to be a fan of on the dice
man yeah I'm like I missed I missed that
he was smoking at the connoisseur and
Bobbie Lee goes are you smoking again it
took ten years off haha
legged hey hit opinions and I'm Bobby
Baris because I've been swimming so I
was a kid and dice goes you should take
some time what a very soon oh he's a
gang these are just such a cure to own a
hangout all right apparently clue
rich really good with money like really
yes but yes I mean waters the premise of
the show is that he gambled so much
money that he has to like be the
comedian at the club for a year and a
half or to make up forever true straight
the Riviera
yeah no he's who told you that be I have
authority I have it on good authority 9
I'm from a very close friend of ours
he's very close within an authority I
think yeah person yeah I've heard he's I
hope he is I hope he is really rich as
you dice clay man very funny I mean he
smokes in airports he's got like a whole
thing like they're like oh I didn't see
you son like he just waits for people to
ask him to put it out and I saw him the
other day we were about to shoot a scene
and he he just turns around and just
discreetly puts the cigarette out on his
palm what's wrong guy is also nice guys
and then he'll he'll uh shoplift candy
for a thrill and then his managers like
what do you do i shoplift and can't like
those little Necco wafers he's like the
better when they're free you got a new
fan yes come in come in he's still funny
- he still you never stop doing stand-up
no he's funny because he's a character
and he's he I mean he's in just things
out he is silly but he also like that is
him yeah he takes himself kind of
seriously in a way but he's like an
absurd person really I'm Andrew
silverstein right yeah yeah there's a
couple comments that play characters on
stage right like heat like obviously
he's gone full yes ice-clad but then
like who's homeboy the the redneck I
marry Kayla back later the Cable guy's
oh just now yeah yeah yeah that blew up
it was just a video doing a radio show
that just ended up talking that
character yeah I mean it's like oh it's
me you know like not really if you do
stand up more you'll see what's your
name again
Brendan Brendan sorry you're one of my
favorite two if I can look that just
hurt it's really well now I'm not gonna
make okay so Brendan as you start doing
more stand-up you'll be like you know
maybe you're your stand-up persona might
be like your evil twin or a better
version of yourself or you know it's
going to be something you know it's not
like exactly how I mean I guess it could
be just things that what he does he goes
whoa everyone will you're like psychotic
on stage right Brian every subtle and
nuanced Daniel day-lewis comic yeah I
really get in the character you're about
shooting on this special are you know
I'm not shooting a special I'm about to
go on tour okay - with your husband
right Moshe and I are doing something we
call the honeymoon tour because as I was
doing research for my show another
period on Comedy Central please check it
out it's takes place in the Gilded Age
so we went to Newport Rhode Island and
learned about all these rich people at
the turn of the century because it was
an amazing time in history because there
was no income tax so these people were
making billions of like the Carnegie lot
of rockefeller they had a billion
dollars a hundred and twenty years ago
you know like that's how rich they were
but this we read about this couple that
went on the ten-year honeymoon and then
came back with a couple kids like these
people were so rich so Moshe and I are
trying to do that one year - no well
we're trying to extend our honeymoon and
yes maybe have a kid it's guys want to
be dating a comic and you perform
together you co-headline of Thanks we
co-headline so we each do you know a set
like a full set and then we both get on
stage and we do live relationship
counseling and people come out to see us
in the hold all day so hold on hold on
hold but hold the phone people think
they're like listen I'm a girl and I
have to come up on stage
oh it's a couple well yeah but there's
certain people who obviously want to do
it but it's been really good for people
because not everyone talks to a
therapist and you know not everyone has
great communication so they go to
comedians to get those and what we have
been married like over a year so I think
that qualifies this car what is the what
do you think the secret is relationship
wise do you have any advice for people
it's only really hard I mean we're going
together for like five years
um I mean I don't know I was asking a
friend for advice about like what to do
when he like leaves its socks everywhere
and shoes
everywhere those habitants open and they
were like just pick up after him and
then I just started kind of doing that
because it's like what are you gonna do
excuse me excuse me can you pick up your
shoes can you pick up your socks can you
close okay I mean I haven't kind of just
trying to let him see that he doesn't
close things behind him just so he get
you cause it's funny right I mean it's
kind of funny to be like where's the
advil and then you tell them and then
you go into the room where the advil is
and like everything's open you know a
wife has no problem yeah you grew up
with somebody doing everything for you I
mean that's not even his faith I think
it's just like like Moses told me before
his instinct when he dropped something
is to run away and just keep going me
that is like - making it up yeah me too
I strike value - just an instinct I like
lady Yeah right that instinct guys you
mean - did because to bend down and pick
it not too much worse a lot my god she's
go ahead you're even worse than most
people about that we have to take a
shuttle to a rental car when we fly in
like he's like oh not that I am dying
wait why what do you hate about it's
just another much too much I want to do
the shuttle why don't you just like take
a cab to the hotel because we need to
kono we don't we like the car Brian
always wants a car I'm like what she
didn't tell me a car done 17 but I like
to cruise the strip you know it's weird
why no ripple what really because I like
a ride and we never used it either we
never used it yeah but you know you want
to roll the windows and [ __ ] ride no
I don't I hate driving over my dad's a
car deal actually my dad is coming to
see me in Chicago and he just texted me
I'm getting a party bus sick right dad
oh yes I'd be so proud of my daughter
was a really good comic though that's
kind of exciting he's getting a party
bus that's is horny guys he's celebrated
he's gonna be so drunk for my show
you're drunk
well one time he brought all of his his
sister is my aunt's and they were in the
front row and they were so drunk they
were like spilling bottles of wine and
then like they came back the next night
I was like can you please be quiet so
then they like wouldn't laugh and they
were like in like a 20-person table in
the front
so whenever a joke would happen I'd be
like oh and though it was like it kind
of affected the entire show yeah another
Rory
your parents together like pretty
standard never have comics use oh yeah
tell me but you're popping comic didn't
get it at least enough love from at
least one parent just searching for
affection your Italian hundreds at a
time
no I'm Swedish as well oh and I am
bouncing all that height yeah I can see
that day you're very pretty
oh thank my wife was watching and she
was she's adorable she's adorable
I met your wife before is it the same
wife he's had I I have another driver
Sheldon I said hi cheated on her so I
have lots of other girlfriends which one
we get confusing is it the one is she
the mother of both your children because
I remember I saw her a long time ago and
she was very pregnant yes she was very
pretty she was very beautiful yes she
was very pretty but you're always you
were always with really hot chicks thank
you spread that around Rose my go till
you're married now yeah whatever she
listens to this podcast I want to
understand what she has how lucky she
got me so residual medium white guy yeah
sorry do you do you and your husband
because I can't imagine living or me
being made to someone who's also in
entertainment so do you guys how does it
work yeah just go your separate ways do
your work could you guys come together
and do it like collab you can't imagine
as you might know because using my
excuse is if I'm busy or something going
on it's because I have to you know I'm
just crazy schedule have a nine-to-five
ever get a girlfriend yes and a baby Wow
and so are you like now you're like hey
can we get some more dates Brian I got a
crying baby at home no never
I feel like all these male comedians you
know they soon as they those babies hit
they go I'm doing the road exact
opposite I will say that I used to sleep
right through the baby crying I never
our dad wouldn't move not any men not me
and you're like part of it oh man am I
ever but the thing is is you're supposed
to sleep Traynham cuz you know this will
sleep through the night be crying us
would I if I hear him cry cannot sit
there and not do anything it well my
wife is a good news to them first I was
not saying she beats me this is like I'm
up man who goes over there and I'm like
okay what one parent has to be like no
no you got
sleep through and I cannot do it yeah
you you're the one you're the softy it
was like a pushover with the kid yeah be
done he can do what you gotta let him do
it or they'll ruin your life not really
awesome I'm going to put my kid to bed
it like 11:00 p.m. so I can sleep in
till 8:10 I know that you know parents
just like whatever why not what does the
kid care you'll have an hour don't sleep
you gotta have money schedule it don't
black out curtains or something yeah
yeah but then when they go to when they
start school know that weird goth kid
yeah she's gotten blacked out of limb I
would much rather have a goth kid than
someone in sports how do how dare you a
toxicology variance you're kidding me
some baller athlete and getting the clue
let's go there well my offer Benny diem
sighs you can't reveal sports you're
gonna be a comic well now there's mall
your truck didn't do it I didn't why
your kids are probably jockeys they'll
be smaller
oh no polos allowed Paul told us or
tennis polo tennis mom I made to the
total feel where's my mallet my mind
fight my horse needs new shoes check
immediately you know what your children
speak this way no shy doesn't call you
by your name you know what kids British
the upper class called their parents by
their first names no thank you
I love it they do that you love it yeah
call their parents mom and dad they call
them by their first but now they call
you no no that's a mom and you called
the Queen Mum okay so uh Kate up there
what's her name Kate okay Jane I didn't
know Kate Winslet
no was a riddled in her her little baby
calls her Kate I'm not sure actually hey
Emma being a Princess Kate may be really
cool I could have them call me princess
Natasha she was that'd be cool well
Royal Highness I keep trying to call my
trying to give them a nickname is real
person names tiger I keep trying to give
them nickname you can wait you're
kidding a Saiga and you're trying to get
him a nickname
yeah the scale is why I named my son
Finn because Finn you can't really make
up a nickname it is a nickname well I
just want a nickname for him I saw Tom
say cooter and then finally Joel ignored
us
that's not sticking click on scooter why
would come see us just really cute
sometimes
- there's no scooter I know just here
Tigers cute is cute yeah I almost named
my son Gus and then I was like oh wow
yes do you want to be a plumber right
gosh Gus but just Gus
he'd just be a drip along just a big guy
like hitting Gus like any class of kids
my grass you know I guess a big boy just
a big old Gus so your kids Finn that's a
good name
it's a ancient Gaelic and it stands for
the triangular growth that juts from a
shark's back whoa come on I'm a comedian
come on Joe come on come on yeah I think
I would do to you if you were my wife I
do my wife is very sort of uh she barely
can stand me sometimes and like my
daughter like I'm sweaty or and I'll do
things like I'll look at her and I'll be
like oh yeah how badly you want some
addition I'll take you off and she go -
your wife - my wife no I taught her very
confusing to my daughter she's not only
how I did my god
she's my daughter she's not really my
daughter but she said 99 don't call me
daddy no be no one yet really you look
tough in Bret win that nanny and this
all iy this is in front of wifey Ossipee
waikiki see this [ __ ] manatee bro
wait ec ously she watched him he does
why did you lie to women hire really hot
after my wedding you're a medium your
wife goes oh prime I was like why would
you hire set you up with her she could
have won Miss Sweden she was dodging I
was like kind of your wife is probably
very confident she's very confident but
I wonder so much to end up like Bennett
I couldn't go Dan think so I was like
bro this is your back you smell funny if
she was setting him up just for like she
wants to get with her that's a great hey
lady - right oh great angle look at our
Swartz Degas I'm not like we dish model
oh my god so hot she was 10 of God's
like what she's a decent Manny - Brian
goes I thought myself checking my hair
before she would come in I'd be like is
this shirt I was like alright that's it
get rid her right now I don't want to
rely on her if she was going back to
Sweden anyway otherwise it would have
been you know Stu uncle and I remember
trying to say
bro I got the I mean this oh my baby
hugging our hump weird eyes yeah
krookodile and are just so horny like
you know like they'll they'll [ __ ] you
know however so she doesn't even have to
be that hot look at all this were saying
is like that [ __ ] it
yeah at a kid with a beautiful kid too
really oh yeah it was like the the
straight-up net-like nanny man yeah like
yeah why do you think men are so horny
testosterone spread our sea life
elevation once we get this we got to
spread a sheet over here if you're an
alpha male like me an apex alpha if in
apex you want a gift do you want to give
the world with your seed with your heavy
load you but I'm sure some of my god
I'm sure done I apologize for my friend
you've known him for a face according to
him you've known him for 30 years for
you you save nice Oh we'd known each
other probably for like 15 yeah yeah I
want us favourite that we can remember
but the thing is this is for you we've
coming up in the comedy world Dom so you
deal with guys all the time like well
now you're married so in especially
since he's a common a guy you're so
waiting on you all the time right or no
but that's not just because you're a
comedian like that's just in general
you're a dominative male kind of arena
especially in 2002 like now it's changed
but in 2002 there was an as many female
tom oh yeah there were some [ __ ]
yeah but you were Teflon yeah I like
care I've seen you deal with stuffing
and I've seen you kind of he was always
like I mean you were always like Oh God
well I used to like cocktail waitress at
the whiskey bar and I had to wear a
leotard and like people would always say
stuff to you and the training camp
economy and then I just people just
stopped hitting on me and I think I was
just like I just got the vibe going
right the rest is like I don't know me
no Natasha always would like I would
always see you once I've ever seen you
get up on stage so [ __ ] hilarious you
essentially had a beehive you walk in
with a mini hive her hair was up and up
be huh I mean I'm honored emulated on it
friend John oh he's so funny in your
head she has like a fur coat on and she
walked in and she was it was like she
just had her nails done and so in other
words get away from me if you know your
mother's I don't sit on that furniture
you're not going in the living room
you're filthy
so two outside guys are characters yes
Natasha wah wah fight
by guys like me basically with the look
of don't touch me I just had everything
done and ya filthy man Pig yeah I'd be
like alright alright I give you kiss
intosh you would do it gently on both
cheeks the way you do the Queen
hey butter my god that's a good analogy
am I wrong the most female comics with
entertainment some if they didn't have
that buy these don't make it no I think
you know I know but I'm earning advance
for doesn't have that vibe but but
here's a compliment to both you and a
lot like you're both very attractive
women and you guys were able to I first
of all keep that male energy like sort
of off because every man started banging
right let's speak much caught water like
Eliza has male energy herself though
yeah but Eliza yeah I don't feel the
same I mean I see a she has more male
energy as a kid say and I her a boss and
I'd say Eliza yeah is very very more
like very much more like Jesus yes she's
got that and that might be a defense
mechanism from having grown up in this
doing this for so long but yeah cuz
she's and she started when I started
she's younger than me like she started
like really uh oh yeah I think she was
like in her teens or something I don't
know
yeah she's very she used to put on shows
she's to head up shadow show at El Cid
yeah and I think she was like 20 when
she started or younger
well anyway go ahead yeah but but I
think that you guys did a really insular
Whitney you guys all did a really good
job of I guess somehow like keeping that
energy at bay not making enemies not
pissing guys off at it getting being
taken seriously by other comics who are
men and you know that that's a big
that's not an easy thing to do that that
is hard to kind of navigate wouldn't you
say yeah and I think everyone doesn't
their own unique way like yeah Eliza I
don't mean she has like a lot of male
energy but she wouldn't like use her
feminine she wasn't like dressing up
like wearing yeah like she dresses down
and that's how she dealt with and
everyone kind of does it their own way
well you guys let your comedy do the
talking for you guys got good enough to
be undeniable you know Sam give me a
couple of jokes I can't do it dude I'll
do a hurry I don't you [ __ ] like that
give us a couple jokes take it day
[Laughter]
Howard Stern I three who he had on via
the leading from coal plating his II
just placed a song he's like uh [ __ ]
they just get you dead stairs could we
just play a song for us that should have
been arranged like you should have known
yeah well I guess you doing something in
the back in the king just get you good
time little C but that seems easier to
me than claim you're doing a joke
oh my god man you're getting there just
you know when he played a something
later how many times yeah are you gonna
come on do a joke on a radio with no
Robin no I'm saying the song seems
easier to do well I did I mean I did
well I saw I did a pilot with Jessica
Simpson we've been shooting all week and
it was like long days and finally there
was a live studio audience and her dad
said would you just they would really
love you to sing one of the songs she
said Jessica and it was like no dick to
the audience and she was like um she was
like I remember she's a really nice
person but I remember she went like a
she went I'm so tired
any good if you didn't she listens her
dad yeah and so we're from the look of a
shoot yes he did actually he did and she
looked at the people they were so
expected as a small group in that high
school girl and she's she's one of those
girls she's like she's she's a soldier
and she was like alright I I will yeah
hi thanks and she sang it a cappella
now she has her she can sing she is
fighting to she can sing sing but not
like British she was hired it was a long
day
and I could really tell that it was a
[ __ ] struggle she sang like a couple
stanzas of it in and she kind of stopped
and she was just like and she walked
when she's like she was shushing a
little embarrassed she was humiliated
because she didn't feel like she was
trying out for handing it off any dad
warmer dad like you got to protect your
energy that's her manage no you know
that's what I amateurs like their energy
is like she needs to perform well in the
next scene and being a good mood and
like that's a very warm a night it was
okay but also they're a good dad as your
manager everyday German a pretty good
job with both of them though and he
loves the [ __ ] out of those girls that's
for sure they have they're a real Titan
and family they still married is what I
mean I was very impressed with actually
that family I got to know Eddie pretty
well yeah Cooper Chris yeah I got to
know them pretty well because I did that
pilot but I was in seventh heaven with
Ashley for two years so I was really
pretty too yeah and I was actually do
nothing
mama I know man I guess she's just a mom
yeah I think so Justin just you know I'm
saying but she had a living in her
sister shadow
did she ever got some surgery done and
all that stuff but I'm usually against
surgery that knows and she had done 100
said better okay that's all well know
yeah well better that Kardashian girl is
better with the surgery the young ones
all highly yeah
have you seen before and afters yeah
these doctors deserve some sort of media
it is on I'm okay at me it made her look
older just so it's like she's like 20
and she looks 40 so it's like that was
the way a young 40 yeah 40 or 50 20 she
went from a basic just skinny flat ass
white girl to just a video vixen in like
two days
like blah and she had breast and ass go
back before no are you telling me the
acid state - she was basically went from
Kermit the Frog but yes bring that oh I
see the body out it's not mr. frog
well isn't it possible she was so young
that she hadn't developed yet it's
definitely not Brian all right i watch
way too much botched to do ha yes so you
so they can do some [ __ ]
oddly - unbelievable what they did with
her man you won't even recognize her
that is just remarkable but then it just
starts here that one in the top corner
that's on the far right that's a good
one yeah because she's like basic there
they're on the wrong side but like yeah
you know like on the left she looks more
like her sister on the right she's like
a like a basic white girl look at that
look at that and they went they
basically went to doctors for the lips
so it's it's mostly lifts yes and then
what else is there this I get my know
what about hi she they did lips chin
cheek implants athlete she grabbed
augmentation ribs there's all sorts of
stuff yes it is like did you do yeah you
put on that examiner picture but see
then they start to they start to look
weird like what's happening to her now
you know what I mean nose is different
it just starts to like the world only
their nose her lips and nose are totally
different some of the most beautiful
women I know who are like in their 50
use when I've asked them their secret
they're like very very little like and
wait till you're 15 yes well that's kind
of a trick like you're not supposed to
like do this at 20 you know because by
the time you're 50 you're going to look
like a monster and what what they're
saying here is you know they did it and
they're trying to make it look so much
like Kim just Kim's getting older and
they want her to kind of take on that
the throne talk about Game of Thrones
you want her to take on the throne from
Kim so that she's morphing into Kim more
and more okay give me that one right
there that would be where she's in her
wish in white there and then in the
black I just like a family really can
only date black guys bless you well
they're both since well shouldn't you
read the yeah but you can see the breast
augmentation man oh right you wanted the
breasts how crazy is that that's a
bummer
I just don't think it ends well yeah and
I don't think younger you know that's my
problem with it is she's kind of the
face for like teens so like 12 to 16
she's freaking as big as they get like
her her makeup Kylie sells out in
minutes like they can't keep in stock
he's not with the makeup yeah and it's
literally anything she touches she and
you want you notice I like the girls
were the jean shorts and they do their
lips take the same way that she does
like she's kind of a role model for
these young teens it's not good cuz it's
all fake it's all it's all none of it is
real she wasn't born like that that's
right
it's a bad and then exactly there's
something wrong with you when you look
like a normal because she's pretty there
is it well I guess if I had a daughter
she's like dad look at 2011-2014 like
that stuffed are you I guess yeah we
tell your daughter
I'd say you know what when you're 18
we'll figure it out if you look like
that on the left you all look like
they're ready on the left
you know she's a kid how dare you you
know well it's depressing
it is yeah me too I find depressing I
mean you've had a lot of work you know
I'm afraid know where your natural are
you afraid you're very pretty of course
it's like who wants to have I mean I
know someone in my family who got their
lips done and it looks weird
yeah I've not had any work done I know
well to your point though you want to I
didn't get my lip you want to wait you
don't need to write but you don't want
to wait because or you do want to wait
because we don't you'll notice they all
sort of look the same if you sound super
[ __ ] up so bear with me it's like kids
with Down syndrome they all look the
same
it's people with people with that say
surgery once they hit like 45 they did
too soon they all look exactly the same
I think so exactly the same it's so
strange
well we just have to there's the
standard for beauty probably that the
doctors are working off of write a
certain note and it changes yeah you
know because like our show takes place
in 1902 so when we're doing casting it's
like some people have really you know
Christina Hendricks was on our show like
she has very classic features like she
looks like someone who could be in the
turn of the century but then when you
look at someone like Jennifer Aniston
she just has this like modern athletic
look this like doesn't feel like it
could work a hundred years ago it's a
compass more modern probably harder to
turn for more exotic I don't know it's
just like trends I'm just saying like I
hear I'm just saying but most girls are
going for that more athletic type of
trend you know like that like well you
can try your shapes really good yeah but
you can your body you can that's true
but the body doesn't really matter if
it's full of you know it's got a costume
on I feel like they'd be the ideal for
women now is more healthy for women than
it was when in the 70s and even the age
when you had to be super skinny that
sounds like the best time I don't know
because what you were so skinny and now
being on speed and smoking and listening
to like cool music all the time and
wearing platform shoes being on drugs
like those like heroin-chic know condoms
when Age came along yangshin we learned
it doesn't work but now people like you
know juice and it's just kind of
depressing to stick to a diet I'm trying
to eat healthy I mean you smoke no I
mean
marijuana yeah a lot like everyday I
would like to smoke every day yeah but
I'm trying to not do that right now you
smoke for creativity or to relax at
night more like creativity interesting
boy doesn't work for me really you guys
use it to sleep
brother this one I use it to sleep I
smoke it is nice to do it your
personality I agree it does you know
like what I'm all
any kind of chill so I don't really need
to be like chilled out my problem is I
can't stop thinking about like business
or next move on to next week or the
MINIX show right but that's what you do
is do but if you oh you can't stop
thinking that in general yeah see I feel
like I am when I smoke pot like it opens
up new ideas come to me like I'll be
thinking about that stuff but I'll be
like oh what if I did dad that's
interesting
I don't know well it's working like I
said it does not your husband smokes to
know he's sober it was an addict before
yeah like when he was 16 so yeah you can
see over here six teens know alex is 16
don't tell him that 36 now motion he's
38 younger man that's so crazy using
that get 16 he what he hasn't tried
anything I mean alcohol is a weird thing
because sometimes people you know the
kind of people I know who are addicts
like when they get back on alcohol it's
like oh I just woke up in Jerusalem or I
just woke up and got into a big fight in
my eyes bleeding and I see this shoe
here and I don't know what happened it's
like you know no but I'm just saying
like alcohol can have that effect on
people because I think he had that I
don't know what his deal is but I'm
saying a 16 of someone when I was in
college songs like you're an addict I'm
like you mean college like this is right
but I'm just saying some people's
chemical makeup I don't
some people are station act yeah you
know don't they're not like are you do
you drink no I can't do everything I've
never been an addictive personnel really
cool we've never been drunk together
ever now I've know you felt it so much I
don't get drunk I'm a mother I've never
been that's um I got drunk high on life
yeah you don't look pot now I can do I'm
one of those guys you can do a line of
the best blow in the world and be like
not gonna do it anymore I can stop you
know well weed smoke pot with Rogan
Eddie on the companion I've kind of went
away from it cuz I find that I just kind
of zone I'm nothing to say when I get
that high I'm just really yeah I just
sit there I'm like I want to say stuff
but I'm wearing them say the wrong thing
when when I'm sober I can just let it
fly are you guys part of Rogen's crew
yeah yeah don't joke I'm not Joe for 22
years really all this running away
that's amazing yeah woman freak
oh yeah I've known Joe I mean Frank was
timet Joe my first year of MADtv which
was 1996 so he's a guest that we were
both training at carlson gracie
jiu-jitsu school all right and he said
yeah I do this Gracie cheated I was like
I want to do that and I went there and
blah blah blah you guys couldn't be
partners though right because he's doing
so much bigger than like he's like more
stock I mean training part yeah like
could you guys change channel yeah you
know you know the ones like me and Brian
could roll I could really or semi I've
rolled with girls I'm not going to do
anything to him but never saying I've
rolled with them that means like I
fought them know you've just like train
together okay build it just you Jitsu
now chance you have to pee now
cuz I do yeah I knew you did I've been
thinking about this whole time
basically great let's let let's helmet
touch thank you
Natasha is gonna pee on you guys come oh
yeah we're going to show you what's up
by the way it's been a disaster so far
let's go where were we so right here
we're back from a pee break feeling way
better with and now beautiful and
Natasha that bathroom is that the worst
bathroom in the world well yours is nice
for the reason ours is bombs over back
how many every guy in there is
destroying the bathroom every time
construction every time we go in there
it is working like a symphony I think
they're eating [ __ ] all day long some
bones just it's how crazy it is here
every time we go in there Jeff Jeff Ross
has that joke he's like it smells like
my crap took a crap I don't know what's
going on
this guy's anyways alright back to and
that's about poo
Natasha um let's talk about where you
want to be in ten years I see my friend
over here James on this show Kurt event
whatever katachi
your your games like things I didn't
want to talk about what I where I wanted
to be in ten years
oh I hear you I hate when people ask
that I don't [ __ ] up I want to think
about it I don't know what I'm doing
tomorrow yeah well do you ever think
about leaving the business of you'll do
stand-up forever
artists don't retire thanks Dana de
luces huh oh I mean I hope I would
always be doing something
Yeah right I mean what am I gonna do sit
at home did you have goals like when you
first started where you like I want a
special I want t v--'s did you this
without the dress of ambition because if
someone told me you know ten years ago
everything I had today I would be like
are you [ __ ] serious oh my god oh my
god but now you're like well why don't I
have that I don't like to go [ __ ]
Tran it sucks because that's maybe
that's why journaling is maybe a good
idea or something like in writings you
can kind of compare it or or take stock
or at least know where Hey look at where
you came from don't compare up nah I did
that when I was fighting his ass
I had a journal I was like man this is
what I want to do with my career and I
look back down like I want a silly
stupid [ __ ]
closed it kept going but then you you
did all those things yeah I did and then
I'm like ah it's what we for sure set
your goals high closed it if I keep
doing it I've actually finally kind of
at fifty kind of settled into being
happy with to a large extent at least
what I'm doing right now I worry it's
not gonna last but like I'm proud of the
podcast and I'm I'm proud of you've
always had a good I mean I remember on
Chelsea Lately you gave me some advice
once and it made me feel better because
I was feeling anxiety about like not
being more popular or whatever it is and
you were like yeah you just always you
know you're always just kind of like
slowly working towards the next thing
and it all kind of is happening you know
don't realize it and you just need to
have like a really good you're like I've
been in this business for 20 years I
haven't you know uh to drop some names
interesting I was in at dinner recently
and the Chris Pine is really cool guy
and he's been the heart of a great
career and then Wonder Woman God the
dough was there and she's doing great
what's her name Gaga Adele Godot her
full name her real name does we don't
know her first name is Gallagher I think
a good dog oh gosh yeah I tried a fruit
in it yeah yeah there's a classic Celtic
Road they were both great yeah her
husband's awesome yeah they were great
in the movie and in Chris Pines one of
us in silly goose great great time money
to no good and Adrian and or what was
those catering it's like that's like we
have a host more but not why were you do
it more prosciutto we all had one then
the other all right I was right there I
was pouring for him
can you guys could you guys reenact the
scene for one woman for me please but I
actually was saying
and but the longer story I'm making
about fame is that in walks
Annette Bening and Warren Beatty now
that's old school
Royal Hollywood stuff I was just
watching and I thought to myself as they
were kind of I was listening to the
conversation they were talking talking
about what all of us would be talking
about dealing with what all of us would
be dealing with but at the end of the
day it's like I mentioned to him
Warren Beatty my generation Warren
Beatty was as big as it gets
he does old school you know as in it'll
hide that no no I said I said I sell
more Beatty was the biggest star I mean
you know yeah thank you very soon he
goes oh yeah yeah yeah well it's cool
like like it just goes away man it goes
away so the idea that there's any sort
of destination you may very well I think
personally you already have you have
your own show and your stand-up is
amazing yes but I say this I'm like okay
like with you whenever we talk about
bringing guests on I only assume you're
killing it I got to know who you are you
don't know him but anyways um Bryan goes
on mitachi oh yeah she's killing it I
started running like a she's at peace
yes I think Bryan's like what you're
what you're talking about is like
wanting that permanent thing which
really when you really think about it
who do you think from our generation is
going to be lasting in 50 years
you know me no one do you mean like no
one I mean last like me was like I'm
still going to be talking about who in
our comedic community in 50 years are
people going to be talking all I never
worry about that I just keep like I said
I just keep writing I keep performing I
keep doing it cuz it's what I do
and if the results are big this year
great if they're not so big next year
that's how what's even hall-of-famers
like even I hate sports but even sports
I was looking at a fighter I was around
the other day and you talking about Hall
of Fame I was looking like all that work
and then looking at I just did a show
the other day with Mel Brooks it was
like a game show just for fun what I was
like a giant legend Superman great they
Ares Falls am i right yeah I mean you
can't get more permanent is Lazenby take
a hand to your face he's good okay
there's three girls three people up on
you know 20 year-olds on stage and
they're contestants and not one
them can name one of his movie I'm not
saying that those are I mean obviously
those are just like an exception but
still mama Claire 20 year old I mean
there's like three of them they probably
weren't particularly on your own
whoo-hoo Paul Newman was yeah but yeah I
think he was you know biggest on the
world heartthrob there so it doesn't
really get that obsession with the
permanent thing like I just watched this
Grateful Dead documentary I'm not really
a fan but it's an amazing documentary do
you guys like music I love documentaries
especially if it's a good one
well the dads are dead Arnold and trips
that's when it's on Amazon and it is
awesome but Jerry Garcia who I didn't
know anything about and listen I've
since I watched this I'm trying to get
into their music and it's showers thanks
to her I can't but her but the
philosophy is so cool and he said what
really shaped him is he went down to
Watts Towers and then do you know what
that is it's like this this man it was
his life's work and he put together it's
in watts in California and in LA and he
put together this like crazy structure
from like found objects and garbage and
it's just been there and it's never
going to move and Jerry Garcia saw it
and instead of like thinking how cool it
was he was like oh this is all that that
permanence thing is like I want to just
have fun yeah and so his whole
philosophy that's kind of why his record
sucks because he's more about the live
performance and like what can I do and
obviously you can't take that too far
because then you die of heroin I mean
that's what I diabetes actually but but
as well he was a heroine yeah it helped
his yeah here with yeah that's not like
you know drugs and fun and whatever
happens you know obviously the weed
doesn't work anymore what sure how that
happened but the point is it's like
having this like thing that's going to
be remembered 50 years after your death
like maybe that's not I know it is that
but that's why you have kids so they can
carry your legacy on or not your legacy
but they can be good people who can
balance out all the ratata idiots well
kind of so that I was talking to Doug
Davidoff about we all just quit now no
no no you shouldn't because I was
talking to David off about this and we
were talking about I've gotten to a
point now where like okay so I can write
stuff that's funny right that's silly
and funny but I've recently been writing
up a storm about what the things I care
about
like I'm way more interested in things
that
bother me and making sort of a
commentary and making that funny that's
challenging in other words being funny
with with something to say I've always
run away from that I've always avoided
that I don't know what also you don't
have to like not everyone needs to be a
political comedian no I'm not I mean I
don't know what would I what I think is
important though is like what's the
responsibility right would you care
about and try to be original that'll
leave a mark and I don't know how long I
live though I don't know how long but
it'll leave it for a little while but
then you're back to wanting to leave a
mark
I am I mean I think but I think all
human beings want some form of
immortality that's why our kids are so
important to us that's why our work is
so important to us leaving a legacy no
matter what it is whether it's but what
I'm trying to say what you're saying is
like no one knows who Paul Newman is
anymore so it doesn't even matter yeah
why concern yourself about not a
nihilist no exactly so you don't do it
for what for the public embrace or the
or the creature comforts you do it for
the work itself the idea that you how
real is that I understand you doing this
oh how real is that I know and let's be
real like if you see another comic on
Netflix purview I'm [ __ ] but why am I
not on there or you know I'm saying like
everyone wants to be relevant or we're
all you're all not around for sure
you're on the same rate relevance is a
little different because that's kind of
what's happening in your well I guess
yeah you want to be relevant in your
lifetime well but you want to be
relevant to make your mark like you if
this day you want to be relevant to make
the crowds laugh tomorrow right like
five but also dimensional art though
right because if you have a special and
you release it on your own website
that's not giving us more relevant
you're not making your mark whether
you're on Netflix community relevant a
dangerous word because YouTube stars are
relevant and then there are people like
George Brown or Richard Pryor who could
be doing or even for that matter Woody
Allen listen to their old stand-up they
could be up at the Comedy Store right
now this drawing and there's something
called classic there's something called
classic work you know things that are so
good that they stand the test of time
what even something like Edberg Rogers
who's yes he wasn't popular enough to
for people in 50 years remember that guy
is a different
you know different you know I think I
think maybe Richard praat well although
I did meet a 20 year old at I didn't
know Richard Pryor was but um you know
maybe who's you know when you said
Carlin I think he maybe in 50 years
people might I don't care about 50 years
oh I'm saying is that there there's
something about when you listen to
cashmere Zeppelin's Kashmir that song it
is you just go you can never stop
listening to it it's always like that
was going to be released ound right it's
a classic but that's logic and I don't
think comedy has the same you know here
here's the here's proof of that just
just listen to who's the guy
what John er sixties what's his name Oh
Lenny Bruce Lenny Bruce look up a Lenny
Bruce joke you're like huh well many but
he was like soul relevant at the time
and so dirty and getting arrested and
you're like he got arrested for that I
don't get it he was a little bit
different in that he was pushing against
obscenity laws and he was testing limits
of the First Amendment and he was sort
of saying I can say this stuff in a
brand of Japanese but now I'm saying it
doesn't it doesn't have that now I can
listen to Kashmir and have the same
feeling that I would ever have maybe
comedies a little different though so
I'm assuming for sure that's what I
would say yes I think I think music it's
not fair to compare yourself against
music no yeah music is like or a great
novel or something emotional yeah yeah
yeah it's an interesting topic but I
think be the only thing you can do is
try to be as original as you can
surprise yourself original yeah that
originality for me that's what I care
about once I want to surprise myself and
I want to do they mean by that beer you
say all the time so till you're ready
topping this not know I get beer is but
when you sue in original obviously if
you're not ERISA you you'll get lost
there other than our derivative right so
yeah but when you say original like
there's so much content out there on
social media on Instagram on Netflix
Comedy Central Amazon I can keep going
whoo there's so many ways where you can
watch comedy on YouTube YouTube bread if
you're not original you're just going to
get lost in the shuffle it doesn't
matter I don't know how many through
that's so original I think that so in
other words you can do something like
Maria Bamford is an example of I think
somebody with a very unique and original
voice so when I listen to Maria Bamford
I don't say ah
like this we're off she was imposed by
this right let's say that's part of what
I like about someone like Maria Bamford
but anything like that for me yeah so
also sometimes I think just surprising
yourself you know kind of just it for
yourself kind of going I didn't know I
could come up with well that's what I
love about writing when you're really
writing an earnest and you come up with
[ __ ] and starts making sense
that's not whether it laughs or not
that's almost the whole deal like it's
like [ __ ] I can't you come up with a
joke or you come over an idea and you're
like like your fish oil thing like that
shit's like we were just like damn you
started without oil he can't he can't
what a funny bit about no pizza not a
bit about visually yeah it's so official
you tell Fisher a lot of a truck getting
your things away you want me to go to
the belly room to hear your fish oil bit
no no this truck he's got strong hands
yes we have that fish until oil comes
out of it into a bowl in your mouth I
got some strong hands anybody want some
fish oil got a [ __ ] I got a tilapia
over here this will get you tilapia oil
oh that's funny
god I'm original um yeah that's what I
think that's right that's that's what I
think I like the idea of originality
yeah but you can't like if you're a
basic person you just kinda have to be
yourself
yeah but there's another there's another
golden then you're really screwed but
there's another reason to do art like a
reward you know there's another reason
to be biting and whatever it might be I
think in a lot of ways you start to get
to know yourself better if you really
say therapy well when you write like
usually if you're writing a story or
you're writing stand-up you pretty soon
get a sense of what you're preoccupied
with and who you really are you
obsessing yeah what you're obsessed with
what you really want what you need you
you really you start to whittle down and
get a sense of who you truly are
do you see a therapist and touches what
this might be too personal I have a sort
of life coach type person who I see when
I mean I don't know I guess he's a
therapist but sometimes this is my role
he seems a little unprofessional so I
don't know if he's exactly why you say
I'm professional I'm sorry a days I go
grab some drinks good happy hour we
talked about is there a lot of hands-on
workers no no no no I just mean like no
he's Moshe put on a Tony Robbins
basketball but anyway he no I mean yeah
I'll ask some questions
he'll help me and he actually helps ya
it's always good to have you know you go
to someone know you know everyone's
always been kings and queens have been
doing that for you know I'm sharing the
game of throne days people were going to
people to ask them what should I do
which one I do like that yeah I wouldn't
ask what the next move is but you have
to guide people I start my person is
really smart
yep I like talking to people who are
smarter than me 100 percent weren't the
smartest person I know I go to him Todd
I heard him about everything he's kind
of a therapist who really charged me
yeah I think of it maybe I should see a
professional you I'm not that
professional yours like just the best
for every talk to a therapist no I died
like twice so Brian do you still do
stand-up or is this your new life no I
understand it do whatever do you do baby
I'll be at the comedy zone on have you
done that in North Carolina now is
Thursday Friday Saturday I only go to
cities that have museums of Modern Art
do they have one of I think I do choose
my decision now nowadays I said no to a
lot of places I'll be like how long in
the winter no Barlett turn-ons drugs'll
you do you do a podcast or no you know I
had one of the first podcast what I know
about that father's a podcast well I had
a podcast like I don't know nine years
ago yeah [ __ ] runs it away and Evan it
was called the lavender hour with Duncan
Trussell oh my god and you're our first
guest dated we live together yes oh and
I remember seeing you both in the
airport don't go to Dodger in the
airport I threaten interrupt you have to
tell a story there in the airport and
they've got [ __ ] masks on no that's
not a yes it was you
like they brought shopping and I go
Duncan whatever we were kidding then I
guess you were but you might hope so but
yes I was like what are you guys
drinking if you have a SARS thing and
you were like we're wearing these mats
Asha would you bring that wait hold on
how do I not remember that call him
right now hotel he'll tell you I
remember it so well so you both had
masks on I was like Natasha really why
are you wearing a mat we were clearly
kidding I would never wear a map you are
joking where is so funny that I
forget things it was like literally
during the stars volatile dude all right
I'm gonna ask him right now I think you
might be confusing me with another
comedy couple would you anyway our first
guest was someone named Chris Hardwick
and he was like oh this is just like you
guys talking then and then we kind of
helped create Nerdist johnson chris is
card which is kicking money from podcast
network Nerdist killing it killed
amazing salted or something yeah for a
billion dollars but it's surgical masks
yeah you were right a surgical man I
remember it like it was you guys do the
podcast for like a year and a half it's
really good you can still get them all
on iTunes all right well don't pick well
yeah for $19.99 you might you can still
get it oh well it's a seven year old
podcast you guys live together um oh
yeah we were a couple
yeah a lot of say well you date you
daytime comics I mean I do which tend to
be I did I am drawn to comedians
you did it Moshe you married him I
married him I married don'tuh for that
Duncan Trussell Duncan's really funny
very time of talking yes the podcast now
yeah Duncan you live in New York without
oh that's right mm-hmm we moved to New
York does move to New York - really
so did Ari those guys by the way they're
at the Comedy Cellar I don't know it
already but they're coming to her every
single night seven days a week who are
Doug Davidoff and all the other comics
you go to commie seller right now every
night you go to the comic sell right now
papo's their first oh dude you were
there I promise you you're gonna see are
you can see Dave Attell you're gonna see
Dave Chappelle you're going to see Louie
CK you're gonna see I mean I know Emma
dating is neato crazy do you go up there
no Tommy stores its Tommy strays kill me
right the seller is crazier Colin Quinn
everybody's down there you're like you
mean it's like all celebrities
oh my god just sucks establish comics
and it is sold out seven nights a week
it's not that big either they have
another one around a corner then a music
venue remember I played yeah how it's a
strictly comedy yes packed seven nights
a week there's that there is for comedy
it's a great time for comedy at least so
I think that I think there's going to be
like
I think the bubble is going to burst
though because I think what's happening
now is no offense what's a good night
man
no good a lot everyone their mom came in
everyone's getting into comedy
so then like people like me and you
Brian we don't want to play these clubs
anymore so we want to go to theater so
the clubs have no one to book so then
they start booking people who aren't
quite ready and then people come out to
the clubs to see a comedy show and it's
not good yeah and then all the bubbles
get burped is a bubble all gets burst
there's a lot of it going on and also
how can we accommodate all of these TV
shows that everyone has like no one can
watch them like my show is so unique and
cool and awesome and well acted I mean
it's starring like David Wain Michael
Ian Black Jason Ritter Christina
Hendricks we have the most amazing show
Dave Koechner
and people can't see it and with a
somewhat you compete with so much well
because we're not on Hulu so you have to
go to comedycentral.com/tosh.o Lex or
dot-com doing option is almost dying or
iTunes I guess you can buy it on iTunes
which is why I buy things on iTunes do
it but you know average the average
person doesn't want to you know who has
like a Hulu subscription and Netflix
subscription and cable they don't want
to buy a $20 season I've been saying
this a lot lately because I see so many
shows Netflix is just making sure to
show that I'm always like how many
people are actually watching that
[ __ ] thing it's so well I'm not like
a different animal Netflix through today
how many subscriptions but also if your
shows good people find it I find it I
know you guys are crying right now but
the thing is is if it's if it's really
good and like with Tommy central I love
Tommy sometimes how do you watch Comedy
Central shows you stay home and wait for
them to come on if it's this is not
happening and I'm on it I'll watch other
than that I don't watch Tommy central I
mean I'll watch South Park something
like that but if their shows were on
Hulu you probably would watch it if is
on Netflix or Hulu yes and that's that's
who you sign with or whatever company
you're with that's they hat they have to
create that vehicle to get you over
hopefully things are you know evolving I
guarantee kaan essentials to smart you
by car if you make it show no they're
going to have to make that transition so
the people who aren't making Chas what's
your transition Netflix dis reaming
dreaming ok Magette have a show and go
hey everyone 8 o'clock Friday nights
watch our show people to [ __ ]
business what no I'm just gonna it has
to be when I want it right when I want
like what will you do that for us
or probably porches the only thing that
stays relevant disdain age where it can
be on it this time you have to watch it
dislike you'll go home to be like I
gotta go west again I do that watch it
later because if games everyone will be
tweeting or fine yeah but Game of
Thrones like the new episode was last
night I just it's on demand for me I
don't have to worry about it can watch
it when I'm not so busy but sports if I
miss it I know that gave me spoil I
watch the finals of Wimbledon last night
I had to watch it when it was on because
I didn't want anybody spoiling it for me
yeah that's a good point yeah I love
tennis I want to sports there's only
thing that doesn't have to make the
transition and even then they're you
know they're they're broadcasting games
on Twitter now on your phone and ESPN on
go and stuff like that I'm amazed that
comes up which it's not stable no they
have a they have like five shows that
are on Hulu like you know whatever their
deal is the bundle didn't include our
show you know it's going Daily Show and
key and Peele and
yeah like three other shows it's going
to though they're going everyone to they
have they have great content like HBO
has a trio go so you can watch all the
shows well they do have a streaming site
it's just it has to be with one of the
BigDog so there's too much to compete
with I'm not going to see you and
network executives correct
if stand-up doesn't work out you be
correct look at this he seems like he
could get a job anywhere it's good at
business he's very good very good at
marketing I guess man the corn you guys
I'm just this you know that's not true
and I'll tell you that no the timer that
is real no you're not are you get a
cheap thrills that all better or at all
sold out I will be no I'm just kidding
you are sold out yeah so no matter both
of you he has a podcast called a big
brown break you had your own pot yeah he
goes he goes on meeting in an exact
because he's forgotten about me and he
goes to Ireland and England and sells
out theaters day what did your podcast
about and here you would hate it sports
okay it's about fighting and also work
for Showtime other stuff yeah cool man
yeah man he made a huge transition and
it's been paying dividends I used to be
grandfathering him into this well you
know people say that he says that but I
think he would have found his way he's a
grinder understand corn
that's really not true I'd be people say
that if you telling women shoot no Brian
knows I don't agree with that
I always correct buying cheap thrill
ticket yeah I love cheap advice it
wasn't for Brian II know I sell women's
read on would have found this way
Brendan would have easily found this way
regardless maybe speaking of on page
either 2:30
oh no Tyler Cheryl thank you for having
me can I promote my tour please do
whatever you want it's a honey hunt all
right waiting for air ah this airs
you're going on we will we start in New
Orleans on Wednesday Sears Wednesday
mota night tonight everybody tonight oh
this this air is Wednesday morning yeah
okay so tonight I'm in New Orleans but
it'll probably sold out by then which is
good so how about so we're New Orleans
then we go to Atlanta Miami Boston
Brooklyn Philadelphia Chicago and
Minneapolis ham can they get tickets up
at my website at tosh.0 calm and you get
to see both me and Moshe doing our shows
better oh and then I lost because
they're both [ __ ] Simone we end with
live relationships I want to go to it
now which is you guys have won LA I know
yeah natasha is one of the finest comics
working period and I'm not saying that
cuz you're here I said it before you got
in the [ __ ] room tool thank you for
saying that
because you told motion got rid of the
word female so that's a big step right
why don't have longer that I don't want
a five female you said for a few new I
always say I got her as my retailer let
first we have it on pay I qualify always
quantified because people they think I'm
talking to my go no no
period she can hang with any no period
she gets a period my favorite comedian
did you get to Syrian so she bleeds at
the end of the day she should be in the
falkland kitchen and she will in ten
years
tell your man said what's up okay do you
vote don't all right you [ __ ] up
everything
Natasha Leggero thank you he where can I
find you really I'm glad you asked
Brendan the comedy zone I'll be there
from the 20 to the 22nd then I fly to
Montreal [ __ ] every life L I'm gonna be
a motel Tamar you yeah I'm doing keppa
Cleopatra where you where you going I
don't know but I'll be there for Sweden
and I Hansel so don't be mad at me but
I'm gonna be I'm realizing why your
podcast is such a hit you have a very
sexy voice oh yes thank you
like kind of wrath that's crazy the only
reason why yeah in order is I just live
my life you kind of got that likes like
East Coast it yeah but you know Rees I
like I live close to the bone
I'm always good hey man hey bro question
back into uh yeah you know you got
sunblock on your legs on the up yeah
somewhat sunblock over my car I don't
need your block up yeah when a guy goes
yeah now watch this that's not Howard
Stern it used interview any stripper be
like really what I am
yeah you still does that awesome every
day still does it he doesn't change
humid did
but yes you have a very nice voice thank
you love it
I will be in Arizona this Thursday Salt
Lake at weight-wise guys on Friday and
that's off to Detroit Toronto sold-out
Chicago get your tickets now back break
that calm this is a five kid Latasha
we're out